welcome back to trues news
we do trues news on the youtube laws and
truths just didn't quite have the same
ring to it do you want to move that
sandwich because uh they don't have
sandwiches on the news
on my news they do have sandwiches right
do you want to finish it all right i'll
probably move yeah i'll probably
uh truth news headline today's top story
american rapper 6 9 has been
arrested again this kid's been arrested
more times than i've uh
had me dick sucked that's a lot of times
do arrests and dick sucking ever cross
over for you
i've actually watched uh a porn uh video
where these two women cops
arrest dudes and then when they get them
sort of in the cell
yeah they're like okay honey now it's
time for you to pay up
and like uh they basically just [__] the
hell out of these guys it's fantastic
and i'm hoping one day
they'll pull me over and then pull me
off right
um so six nines being arrested uh the
majority of cops are men
what is on her lips yeah it's lipstick
is that just lipstick yeah it looks like
um
talcum powder or something else but they
never pop up i got the drop
everybody watch out on my [__] so you
know we hopped out
we gonna show what we about i remember
we watched this the day that it came out
and you watched it about five times that
day yeah i was fascinated by him he's an
interesting guy
um how many gangster up as kiss a puppy
on the opening
of a you know what make me look real
hard there's a childish
charm about this guy but then he's
covered in tattoos on his face
he's got rainbow hair yeah there's
elements of him that remind me of like
other rappers so like he sounds a bit
like a little john
uh or dmx back in the day but not quite
as hard
like if you hit dmx with little john his
his rhymes are like dmx his
his flow is like and then on his weird
sort of bred him with some a packet of
skittles
but there was a point where the older
rappers were sort of reaching out to him
and going
you need to call the [__] you need to
calm the [__] down [__] you
fat joe sat down and said look i
remember when i got a lot of money
i remember when i was being
controversial you know making plans to
come and
you know take all my stuff take me to
prison take me away and he said that
happened only to him but to other people
as well
and when people blow up that's what
happens he was like be careful
he hasn't done that uh literally
he's done the opposite of that i do want
to watch his video for one other reason
as well
why that one right that switch you know
i do often think there is actually a
distinct
lack of women in uh rap videos on
youtube
it's as if they're lonely little boys
so he's been arrested the fbi have came
after him and they've got
footage of him where he's been involved
in robberies
you're wondering what the [__] is he
doing like when when they when his mates
are going out robin and [__]
and not putting people up at gunpoint
when you watch his interviews
on breakfast club he has the most
entertaining interviews like as
someone who interviews people and you're
always trying to get [__] out of people
he's just given
he's constantly giving you content every
[__] five minutes can be
clipped up like the guy is entertaining
he's smart and he says controversial
[__] but he's not smart enough to just
stay indoors when all his mates are
doing [__]
what six nines should be thinking is a
bit of a multi-millionaire these days
mate don't need to go out robin anymore
and instead he's like yeah sure that
sounds like fun
why not there was a load of controversy
about his tour got called off
he's saying loads of people have robbed
me of money i'm firing everyone around
me
and then within a week of firing his
whole crew who apparently robbed him of
money or some people had he gets
arrested and now
it's 25 to life he's facing if this
happens and this goes bad
like this this is a life sentence almost
do you know what i mean we're gonna see
a old ray moorhead 50 year old rap
coming out that will have grown out you
know what i'm saying do you think the um
do you think the issue is as well he got
rid of people who maybe held key bits of
information 100
this is how bad it is he offered his
entire bank account
for the bail money everything he got 1.7
million he had in the bank
and the in the courthouse go and [__]
himself so you know
that they're planning on getting a few
years in prison from this guy
now forgive me if i'm wrong but he looks
like one of the first people who the big
guy in prison would be looking at going
you got pretty much colored hair boy you
better come over here
the whole point of this is like he's
supposed to be having a career to
provide for his daughter and [__] like
that
and now he's in prison he's [__] all
because he just didn't play it smart
yeah you know what i mean like fat joe
told him don't get me wrong do i feel
sorry for him he's a
he's [__] stupid for doing this but
the point is we haven't really seen
a rapper in a long time come out of
nowhere and just go like that and
putting out
hardcore rap music like that we haven't
heard like that from yeah it's like
gangster up stuff
the world these days just will not
tolerate that by the sounds of it it's
just like yeah
[__] you mate like we're not doing that
anymore i'm not really sure what went
down so i don't want to like give the
exact
facts but you know involved with a minor
uh he claims it was like he was a
teenager she was a teenager
but he's had to be on his best behavior
for that i don't think that 69 is the
type of dude who's got [__] kiddy
pawn on his computer
by any means but he was in a [__]
situation he shouldn't have been in
and now he's being told recently you
better [__] keep your nose clean and
within a week
the feds [__] do let us know what you
think in the comments what's gonna
happen with 69 oh my god this guy with
the fat neck
fat joe fat neck from one to another
from one to another now if you're a
criminal and you have something which
gives you away
how do you think they described him when
the police came to the crime scene i
genuinely
have a 20 inch neck yeah what the [__]
is this guy got i mean that's like a
thigh
isn't it really [__] i'm going to ask
you because you're the only person i
have reference for how do you work
these bits so like there's exercise i've
seen mike tyson doing when he was born
where he's sort of um he's leaning over
um a bench and he has like a strap
behind his head and he's like raising it
right with his neck but that means
[__] punched like what you're going to
do a thousand of them that neck tattoo
is more like a chess piece
really the size that looks that's that's
michelangelo do you know what i mean
the sheriff's office posted this mug
shot he's up there was neck in charges
do you think he's one of those guys he
walks around and women women are
attracted to him like they go wow that
is a powerful neck
he looks like there's something wrong
with him he looks stoned
so you see this fine piece rachel
ostervich she basically
had been beaten uh by a by a husband
how big is her husband punched me
repeatedly in the face
head ribs making me fall to the ground
she petitioned for a restraining order
which was being granted that's her
gust for breath and escaped through the
balcony coughing up blood several times
cracked her orbital bone so you know
that bone yeah yeah like
he's [__] her orbital bone so
obviously people will say why i enjoy
um her
i mean this is not a woman who's going
to go to the police for no [__]
reason is what i'm saying
right she's a tough cookie yeah yeah
chocolate chip
like she is a bad [__] you know i mean
and i say that with all due respect i
think if you start on her
she ain't going to just [__] [__] if
he attacked her in a certain way then
sometimes you're defenseless
this is what this is the thing what i
say a few times to people in the past
when they talk about women's mma
fighters and now like i would talk about
logan paul a while back and how he would
take the woman's
champion and i'm like this isn't a knock
on the woman's champion no but people
don't realize
the difference between a force a woman
in general and a man
is astronomical very often just
genetically so [__] different but
this kind of girl she's not going to be
with a guy her size no she's going to go
for an alpha male
right and unfortunately it sounded like
this so
well that's very sad throw away the key
lock the bastard
yeah wife beaters do deserve bad things
speaking of the fight-related industry
so
this uh is the fight between
chuck liddell and tito ortiz the third
one so when i first started watching
fighting
these were the guys yeah you know what i
mean these were the the conor mcgregors
of their day
yeah but now they're old men yeah and
they just need a fukud
they're they're doing this through oscar
de la hoya who knows precisely jack [__]
right about mma but is also up for a few
quid oscar de la hoya
tries to describe the fight that's
taking place here we all know he's taken
a few punches to the head
yeah and also well let's just say he's
had a good time in his
life as well if you know what i mean
just to put this in perspective for
everyone here the point of a press
conference
is to get you excited for the fight
that's about to take place
listen to oscar de la hoya golden boy
mma uh presents chuck liddell t
ortiz once again chuck liddell uh not
lydell if you're going to put on a fight
at least know the name of the fight this
year
promoting there true gordy over here yep
as you know these guys have
um a lot of history amongst each other
someone died i have no idea because this
really feels like a man who's trying to
martha was a beautiful woman
there were a lot of good relationships
amongst her life you know
he's given a eulogy he's giving a eulogy
that's probably because both these
careers are over but
this is sad r.i.p did he just check his
palm i'm pretty sure he looks at his
left palm here
maybe he did didn't he doesn't look like
there's anything written on his palm
maybe that's the problem here is he
he's like he's [__] i forgot to write
anything down he sweat the notes though
he wrote full essay before yeah
[__] i've sweated that'll teach you [__]
sniffing all that [__] before you go out
there
i mean if you were to ask me
um you know who your
favorite fighters are
this is this is this is just the worst
isn't it this is the i love press
conference i've watched thousands of
them
i've been in one of them and i've been
in a bad one in fact i mean stop
throwing [__] because everyone's gonna
go home this might be the worst ever
because i'll tell you what imagine
people were throwing [__] stuff at
him right now
and might wake the [__] up to be honest
would be fair he'd probably tell him to
go home
do you think i was too uh to think of
all of the uh the times i've had things
thrown at me
for the longest time um
they've been fighters who uh who we've
gone to
grow up with fighters we've we've gotten
to know
this this right here is evidence of why
towels should be thrown in earlier in
boxing matches to his brain
do you know when you uh you wait for
your microwave to sort of warm something
up
that's what it's like waiting for this
[__] to finish a sentence you're just
like
let's finish your word any minute now
yeah you know what i'm saying
basically there's a fight on uh lydell
ortiz
might watch it they're basically 40
odd-year-old 50-year-old men
right to me this is the ufc equivalent
of when hulk corgan and randy savage
would like battle it out
later on in life who's the better
fighter for you of the two
in the time chuck mattel was was the
really he won both fights how did you
rate two
ortiz oh two it was pretty good do you
think he's got a chance in this fight oh
i think you'll win this fight really
let's look at chuck liddell hitting pads
now he's an old guy
yeah but it's quite stiff now isn't he i
mean he's about as flexible as a steel
rod
it's like someone's throwing a chair in
the room it's not the quickest hands
you've ever seen that's also incredibly
casual isn't it
i mean i mean don't get me wrong there's
no doubt there's power behind those
shots
also i think it's difficult for a man of
his age now to be keeping him peak
physically let's be honest right
i mean i was having a good oscar chuck
liddell isn't exactly the best guy at
meeting sentences either they've both
got one
very clear white powder in common right
with their past types okay i love diggy
breaking news right breaking sorry this
is how they do on the
and we have some breaking news
[Music]
um 50 cent is basically pointing the
finger
at hot 97's ebro um who famously
uh refused to have six name perform at
summerjam right it's a big event in new
york
um evil began the segment by reading the
facts from justice.gov
and then used the information to set up
his argument and then says y'all want to
end up in jail he rhetorically asked
abro also reads statements sent directly
to hot97
from the nypd saying nypd told us
by the end of the year takashi 69 would
be either dead or in jail now this comes
from our source at the nypd
50 goes i don't understand why nypd
would be telling ebro
yeah information about an active
investigation he must be working with
them
he said they told him in july that by
the end of the year this was happening
oh [__] so 50 is just staring it he's
staring he doesn't like ebro
zebras basically pointed the finger at
50 for killing
rap in my in new york and saying that um
he was in with jar rule as well
like well anyway someone sent us a video
to watch in
if you just search insane kane he paid
world star to have this on he paid them
to go and get it when the heat is on
every day it feels like me life is
beating
on so fake [__]
the matrix do you know the ones who the
white dreadlocks yeah the twins
this sort of plays what we were saying
the other day about [__] uh little
zando like you can it's
this easy a lot of people have said
since you don't know lil zan
how can you make fun of him he's helped
a lot of people with depression blah
blah blah
is this blatant massive amount of drug
you set in a good example is it
i don't know the fact that he's
constantly off his test so look on my
face
they're looking for direction and he's
like
twerk stand and dance twerk yeah can we
can you
do you have an ass yeah can you move it
i'd like it if she pointed the gun at my
head and went
no eat my [__] [__] right so like you
you realize what you've done
you've not reacted you've not you've not
really you've basically just made up a
scenario in your mind
yeah a local rapper from somerville
along with three others have been
charged with
kidnapping and aggravated assault i love
how he's using the new story
that's when you don't give a [__] three
months oh this is dramatic now
and then the words disappear tell you
what i want what i really really want oh
i actually would think that scary spice
would beat him in a fight
absolutely putting money on it yeah
oscar de la hoya signing them off
in my day like rappers were people who
you probably wouldn't want to piss off
with this guy you just think nothing of
it
yeah yeah you just think who are you
yeah sorry so you got you got some
you got some dreadlocks and a chain well
done mate if he is that's his girlfriend
which i'm assuming it is
i'm not definitely don't let her give
you a pokey bump monk because uh
those nails would be savage on their ass
pbw
definitely take precaution now you
remember deji
just last week making waves at the
esports awards when he announced the
wrong winner
now this is a dead youtube channel oh no
my favorite reaction is simon's of
everyone because he's like oh that's
family that was clipped up and
and sent to deji by a a lot of people
pretty sure deji responded i have good
news and bad news
important dead she's
tattoos titles crack me up he is such a
funny man i
find this so funny honestly i find this
is this is hilarious that he's not
laughing though
yeah that's the funny thing about it you
know randolph said this
the way he just said run randolph
randolph randolph said this but the
reason i find it funny is because
randolph you are literally you are the
sidemen as well as jj's [__]
are you smelling a a boxing beef are you
smelling a bottle and i think con's
annoyed because khan wanted that
randolph boxing
connor and randolph were supposed to box
but randolph was a leapfrog corning gone
straight in at main event status yeah
you're jj's camera man he pays your
salary i mean you spend more
time with jj than you do your own wife
randolph has a wife
what can we let's all just slow the [__]
down all right can we confirm though
that there's nothing sexual going on
between randolph and jj it's
purely platonic absolutely and there's
nothing sexual going on between randolph
and his wife because who would find that
attractive this is an exclusive on the
true news
nothing sexual between ksi and randall
absolutely that is an exclusive these
are two asexual men you come up to me
being all nice and [__] and then you say
[__] like that behind my back
in a video publicly that's not cool very
the very definition of things in a
public video that is not behind
someone's back
i just need to be absolutely clear about
this how dare you say things behind my
back in public
tomorrow oh exclusive can we exclusively
this will be our ages ago we've got an
exclusive on the trollsnews
you all know him he's just told us he is
shooting a diss track video
with randolph so expect to see a man
alone in a smoky well-lit
environment very soon you've got to give
credit to randolph i mean whatever you
think of him
he knows how to play the youtube game oh
yeah he's thinking to himself i'll grow
a beard i'll get a handsome southern
light to do a podcast with him where
does he get his ideas from
huh oh hi i'll tell you what the plot
thickens another update on the six
nine case uh takashi 69 has been
transferred to a new facility
apparently it was roughed up a little
bit in the old president and this
facility is
used for witnesses who cut deals you
feel you know what
you fear for this kid in prison though
you know what's interesting about it is
he he's one of those guys who could and
excuse the phrase go either way
do you know what i mean all right moving
on some of you out there will remember
the food reviewer he does reviews on the
youtube now
uh yeah you found another food reviewer
i found another guy
who's like the food reviewer i don't
believe this
there can be only one food reviewer man
hey everybody welcome back
and i may be crazy but i'm close to 70
subscribers and i just wanted to
do something insane he was close to 70
subscribers he wanted to do something
insane
it's kind of insane but i'll show you my
setup before it starts i won't be able
to show you much then this is very
similar to a vikkstar video where vicky
will show you the setup in his flat do
you know what i mean i've got a little
story about vic
so i was at cal friezy's birthday party
i don't know if people have seen any of
the instagram stories for that but it
was
eventful pretty funny and at one point
me and zach are just having a
beer together and vic comes over and
goes i've got to go back downstairs and
get me trainers
now and bear in mind everyone's upstairs
we're all drinking everyone's pissed
there's beer everywhere
and he's took his shoes off and i was
like why the hell did you take your
shoes off
it was one of it was like a home alone
moment you know like i felt like
more than harry and i was like what and
he's like these socks are all soggy
i was like how the [__] is this guy one
of the richest people i know
soggy sock vic vic say to everyone when
i had soggy socks when i was younger was
very different reasons
i've got my water for boiling couple
magazines
do something an extra propane cylinder
which you'll see in a minute do not let
a kid
have a [__] propane cylinder do you
know what i mean i don't think the food
reviewer would put himself in any of
these harsh conditions
oh no absolutely he would be tucked up
tight at home after his mother kissed
him good night this guy's a little
harder yeah than the food reviewer this
guy has learned over time
to be a hard man wow he he won
[__] that is gonna be a cold night
yeah he's gonna have a window open
yes his kid is hard
can i just say he also starts every
scene
by saying the phrase everybody even
his his full mole paper is like the
earth in his mind
he's a great survival expert but in
reality
he's in the back garden with a [__]
tent i'm gonna go
in there and i'll see you next time i
start filming
i'll see you next time yes so far
i'm still i'm freezing and the time
he's now gonna tell us the time again
he's gonna tell us the time again
because in his mind it's can he survive
the night that's what this
is yeah it's survival just remember this
last time he told us the time it was 5
14. all right what time is it now
20 minutes later i'm just gonna keep
updating overnight it's freezing out
here i don't know
go in then you literally live 10 feet
away from this tent
his body is slowly shutting down and
he's oscar de la hoya in it now i'm
getting into it i'm praying for the next
cut off so you can get the
update i want to know how this is i want
more updates i also miss anything
it feels like anything could happen in
this tent anything anything's possible
here's what's also weird
part of me is thinking nothing's gonna
couldn't even sleep
no animals are in there it's just the
snow i mean look at that
but yeah i just i just wanted it's the
first time we see the artist on camera
you love you love chubby lads i just
love i love their
uh their demeanor i've seen this before
i get the feeling
you you may have seen okay you haven't
seen patrice evra
mint chicken
why would you do that with raw chicken
can you remember when patricia was just
a footballer remember it was just a left
back a really good one
and now he's just some plunger i just
think he's a bit mental
that's that is crazy isn't it he's just
mental isn't he that is
[Music]
reviews on the crazy you never knew such
a cool dude
i keep it so flat and do you know why
because i know whether to buy that food
reviewer here hey guys what's going on
it's fruitviewer
um sorry about not having a lot of
videos lately i've been busy with some
other [__] i've been busy with a lot of
[__] nice busy man i mean what have you
been busy with we just got braces for
one today we are reviewing
popsicle brand obstacles
how simple is that i love that so i love
that what he did remember last time we
watched
he just found something in the bottom of
a cupboard you make content about what's
around you
you've got to make do make do yeah
that's what i love about him but i also
love the fact that here he is
making content and then what he's tried
to do is pass it off
as if it's a really simple nouveau piece
of cooking where he's gone
it's just simple this is a dish that i
love the popsicles that's all the
processes are off yeah exactly it's a
classic
it's a staple of the american diet yeah
it's an amazing staple as well here we
go
i'm not really a big fan of popsicles i
don't know
i don't know really what it is i think
because they're so cold and it just like
hurts
it hurts my teeth kind of that's just
it's gonna that might be that might be
why they're hurting your teeth mate
um you're supposed to suck on a popsicle
and then maybe as it sort of warmed up
then go for it
not just chew them like a doggy treat
actually and the flavor kind of burst
see what i mean though the flavor kind
of bursts i love that no one else says
things like this
he does think of things that a normal
person wouldn't think to say about
the most basic [__] one thing i really
loved about this was a for some weird
reason he's wearing a chef's hat well
that was supposed to be a hint of what
his next video was about but
we'll never know because he didn't hit
totally just sat and chewed on a yeah
popsicle today we're gonna be doing
something a little different we're gonna
be starting like kind of like a versus
series
uh we're gonna go to mcdonald's and
we're gonna go to burger king i think he
literally just woke up one day and
thought i quite fancy both of these how
do i [__] justify this how do i
justify this the irs i want a burger
king burger with mcdonald's fries
i'll just have an order of the
mozzarella sticks please is that gonna
be all
uh that'll be it what he did was edit
out the bit where he goes actually
i'll have and then he just rattles a
whole load of order off
can i just say that shot was almost
cinematic the way that he drove away
there is it just me right
i want him to be so happy i see guilt
in that face when he's getting the food
i feel i'm watching someone
feel guilty about it yeah do you see
that yeah absolutely but
like you know it invokes a deep sadness
in me do you know what i mean
if he was born somewhere else or was
born and he had other influences
this guy could be a presenter or a he
could be an actual food reviewer
somewhere
but instead he's not got that
opportunity right now
but maybe in time i hope he gets that
four mozzarella sticks and then it's a
dollar 39
over at mcdonald's for three
but i got the diet coke which by the way
doesn't have ice in it
what the [__] i would love it if if one
of the
mcdonald's staff overheard him they were
just walking past and they go
sorry what was that yeah and looked
through his window i you know he would
just shrink
nothing he would shrink like a cold
penis but i wouldn't want him to i want
to train him to unshrink
no no i want to train him to be who he
really is i want us to
bring him out of that yeah i want to
meet this kid that's what i'm saying
so here is the
i can't see it look you could be holding
up a thumb or literally like a
[Music]
wow that's is that a first on the food
reviewer channel
is that our first wow no no he's
definitely said well once before but not
to that sort of level that was yeah that
was a big one
wow i can't believe he's showing this to
the camera right now
i can't believe you've shown it to the
camera and we can't actually see it
it'll be pointless if we could see it
it feels more pointless because we
cannot see it although i can crystal
clear see uh
the shops saying that it's a beautiful
shop size
we've all been there when we do when we
leave something going when we're
recording let's go and try this
that should not happen yeah he's not yet
you know
that's that's a fundamental flaw in the
rulebook
this should not happen first the radio
ah the whole bk one came out of the
casing though what is he going to have
to say about that
that can't be good the casing was not
attached to mozzarella
that's what's happened there yeah all
right mcdonald's
you gotta step up what a game i would
love the mcdonald's bosses to be suck
they're going
damn it i told you the recipe was never
good enough from the start
ronald just threw someone out a window
he just confirmed everything already
said
and the mcdonald's ones taste like
mcdonald's mcdonald's has a certain
taste
this guy has a little bubble that he
lives in i just really would love him to
meet the woman who would have these
conversations
with absolutely and argue and challenge
his opinion absolutely we need there's a
girl out there
who just wants to sit and have some
cheesy mcdonald's and burger king
at the same time yeah nonetheless you've
got to be able to do the mutual thing
a woman who'll be willing to say no no
but mcdonald's mean this and he went
oh and go both ways exactly she's got to
go both ways on this yeah and she's got
to be able to confront his opinion
mcdonald's has the better cheese all
right out of 10
mcdonald's five wow half that's average
definitely a little harsh not harsh but
trivial he's the food reviewer you can
see what he wants
burger king on the other hand i'm gonna
go ahead and give him like a seven i i
would have thought from his reaction he
would have given an eight or a nine i
think the thing is right pay attention
to what he's been doing
i have he's went to burger king he's
traveled to mcdonald's he's waited seven
whole minutes in that time taste buds
salivating away getting excited he first
bit into the burger king one i guess
at that point anything's gonna taste the
ten right
he's let it settle down it's now a seven
i understand what you're saying it's
calm down yeah yeah yeah just so good
it's like when you first put your dick
in a girl it feels ten days better than
what it really is
if you've enjoyed this episode of
trollsnews make sure you let us know in
the comments below
uh what you want us to talk about on the
next episode lingus videos to watch
everything tweet us both on twitter at
lozcast that's true geordi tg all of
that good stuff
some people have done really good this
week actually really really well and
clutch i appreciate that yeah we're
nothing
without you a lot yeah yeah that's
[__] that's rubbish yeah we'll be
fine
we're everything thanks for watching and
we'll see you later